- [Man] Big old headache.
And I ain't never gave you none.
All these years, I tell
her, but I cannot get her
to lay down under me to save my life.
(car engines grumbling)
(men chattering)
(metal clanging)
(horn honking)
(traffic rumbling)
♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
(metal clinking)
(car engines grumbling)
- [Mark] Sara.
- [Sara] Yes.
- [Mark] Sara, so where
are you from originally?
- [Sara] I was born in South Bronx.
I grew up in Brooklyn.
- [Mark] All right, how
long have you been out here?
- I've been, L.A. maybe about two months.
- [Mark] Oh, you're brand new.
- Yeah, I've been in
California since July.
And then I was in Vegas,
May 12th, I came to Vegas.
That's actually the first time
I'd ever even left New York City.
- [Mark] Yeah, wow.
- Yeah, pretty crazy (laughing).
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood,
you grew up with both parents?
- Nope, I actually was found, as an infant
in a trashcan, hours
old, and I wasn't born
in a hospital or anything.
I was born in a public bathroom
and thrown in the trash can.
I was found by the cleaning crew.
And I grew up in Brooklyn Home For Girls.
- [Mark] You grew up in a home for girls?
- Yeah?
- [Mark] Wow.
- Yeah, Brooklyn, I was
the only white kid within,
white person within 10 blocks.
And when I was born, I was kind of funky.
She had me on her own
in a public bathroom,
so this leg was turned in like this.
I just, how natural that is.
- [Mark] Right.
- So I had like, the Forrest
Gump leg braces my whole life,
which makes it extremely hard.
I mean, I grew up in
Brooklyn Home For Girls.
There was at, every time,
minimum 100 girls in there,
ages birth to 18.
There was only six nuns that ran it.
A fucking shit show, complete shit show.
Girls were literally, like,
trampled to death over food.
We had at least a death
a week, every week.
- [Mark] Really?
- Absolutely, and this was in the 80s.
I mean, I'm gonna be 38.
So this was, it was pretty morbid.
So now mind you, I'm a little white kid
and I got 100% Jewish blood.
I mean, look at me.
Nuns hate Jews, we killed Jesus right?
So not only that, is
that I'm crippled too.
And I mean, I was very crippled.
I mean, leg braces, thick
Coke bottle glasses.
Little homely, I was the ugliest kid
you ever fucking seen
in your life (laughing).
Like the ugliest kid.
- You wouldn't detect
that now.
- Ugliest kid in the world.
I was pale, pale, pale
white, frizzy, curly hair.
I was a fucking hot mess.
So (laughing), now, but mind
you, I was there since birth.
So having these leg braces and everything,
they didn't take time to teach you things.
Like, "Oh, this is how you
use a spoon," and this that.
No, so they never helped
me go to the bathroom,
like, potty training and stuff like that.
With these leg braces it was
a bitch to use the bathroom.
- [Mark] Sure.
- And so every time I'd have an accident,
they'd bring me in the
bathroom, strip me butt naked,
and beat the shit out of me
and leave me there all night.
So I identified at a very
young age, at three years old,
that if I don't eat or drink,
that I won't have accidents,
so I wouldn't get beaten.
And I was diagnosed with
anorexia at three years old.
- [Mark] Just because you found out-
- Yeah, just from, I
didn't want any attention.
I just wanted to just fade
into the background, you know?
But I was treated just
kind of extra heinously.
I was also, I had third degree
burns at eight years old
from a pot of coffee
that a nun threw at me,
because she said we had
personality conflicts.
I was then sent to Boston
Children's Hospital.
I spent three years there.
I was in a wheelchair
for those three years.
They ended up re-breaking parts of my body
and my back and my hips
to straighten me out.
And I had third degree
burns, I had skin grafts.
Half my boob's fake and everything.
So that, but you know what's really sad is
those three years I spent at
Boston Children's Hospital,
I actually think those were
the best years of my childhood.
It was the first time I ever had,
I mean, I never had a birthday,
I've never had a birthday
cake, ever in my life,
even to this day.
But I got Christmas presents.
I was never allowed to
participate in things like that,
because I was Jewish.
So it was pretty crazy,
it was pretty wild.
- [Mark] It is.
- Yeah, and so, it was pretty cool.
I survived, I went through
and that was one thing,
I would walk everywhere.
I don't care if I had the nicest,
most beautiful car in the world.
I will park that bitch and I will walk.
I will walk it out,
because I know what it is
to not be able to.
And I'll never take physical
things for granted, you know?
I've really been compromised
more than once physically.
And life's short.
If you can do it, get up and do it.
I mean, I'm 38, I'd had four kids.
I'm in the best shape of my life.
- [Mark] Yeah, you look amazing.
- Yeah, absolutely.
So, with that, all that, now.
Brooklyn Group Home for Girls.
My first love, first time I ever had sex,
I got pregnant (chuckling), 15 years old.
- [Mark] Oh (chuckling), 15.
- Nobody knew I was
pregnant until three days
before I had her.
I hid it, because I was afraid.
I was an orphan, I was afraid
the state would take my kid
and everything else.
I was just scared.
Not even the kid's father knew.
And this is back in the day of JNCO Jeans
and the big sweatshirts
and it was winter time.
So, and now mind you, I
grew up on East Coast.
So we had winter, it
was serious (laughing).
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah, I was just able to hide it.
I weighed 141 pounds,
nine months pregnant,
when I went to go have my baby.
My baby was seven pounds, one ounce.
That's the biggest I've
ever been in my life.
That's crazy, right?
Nine months pregnant, she
was perfectly healthy,
100%.
- Now you're a mom.
- Yup, 100%, I had her, got
pregnant at 15, had her at 16.
Now, mind you, she was born,
all my daughters were
born on holidays, as well.
So my oldest, my first born,
was right on her due date,
which was May 28th, Memorial Day, 2000.
Was pretty cool.
I was 16.
I'd never even held a
baby until I had one.
So that was pretty mind blowing.
Now, on my 16th birthday,
just before I had her,
on my 16th birthday, November 7th,
I emancipated myself from the state.
I became my own guardian.
I got my driver's license that day.
I signed my first apartment lease.
I went to high school that morning.
I worked at Pizza Hut that night.
All being pregnant that day
and nobody had a fucking
clue what I was up to.
And so that was pretty
cool, that was pretty epic.
I graduated high school
a year and a half early,
valedictorian of the school.
The school was so,
and now mind you,
I was pregnant with my
second kid at that time.
I got pregnant at 17, had her at 18.
The school wouldn't, kicked
me out, they wouldn't let me
march with the class.
They actually mailed me my diploma.
And I was just, I was really,
I was really hurt by that.
While I was breastfeeding,
everyone was at the prom.
While everyone was graduating,
I was popping out another kid.
It was rough.
- [Mark] Mm-hmm.
- I had my second daughter,
Tatiana, Easter Sunday, 2002,
which was March 31st.
She was amazing, epic, Easter Sunday.
She was actually the only baby
born in New England that day,
which was pretty cool.
- Wow.
- Yeah, she got, like, a special
thing from the President.
(laughing) It's pretty cool.
Yeah, that's Tatiana.
And then, yeah, I graduated high school.
I was always with my kids' father,
from time the time I was 15,
right up until last summer.
So that's, it was 22 years.
Crazy.
Love of my life.
He's the father of all of my kids.
He was the love of my life, absolutely.
I had my third daughter,
Justice, 4th of July, 2004.
And then I had my last
daughter, Jacqueline,
Mother's Day, 2006.
- [Mark] Wow, all holidays.
- Yeah, yup.
Now I did really great.
I was super smart and graduated.
I have four master degrees.
I did culinary, hospitality,
small business management,
and marketing.
I actually owned my own
dress shop in New York City,
custom dress shop for
about, almost 15 years.
I also had catering on the side.
I specialized in expensive
parties, bar mitzvahs, weddings,
stuff like that.
- [Mark] So let me back up a little bit.
- [Sara] Yeah.
- [Mark] You never had
any family or parent?
- [Sara] No, not at all.
I still don't.
- [Mark] Nothing.
- [Sara] Nothing.
- [Mark] Not from birth
did you have anybody.
- [Sara] No.
- [Mark] Zero.
- [Sara] Zero, I was put
in a trash can, yeah.
- Crazy.
- Literally, yeah.
Just the emotional support and stuff.
And one thing I remember-
- The trash can
was your mom.
- Yeah, yeah, literally.
And they don't even
know how I survived it.
It was just crazy, but now mind you,
I was extremely small,
malnourished, everything.
I mean, it was a shit show.
Now, I guess my real
mother, I mean, her family
had no idea, nobody had a clue.
It was pretty crazy.
Yeah, that was pretty crazy.
- [Mark] Wow.
- And now, one thing I remember
as being a child is, like
even now to this day it kind
of fucks with me is that
nothing was ever mine.
Like, in the home there
was a bin of underwear,
there was a bin of shirts,
there was a bin of frigging pants.
We had them, like, jail
roll-out mats for beds.
I wasn't allowed to touch the silverware
or the plates or anything,
because I was a dirty Jew.
I wasn't allowed to sit on the furniture.
I wasn't allowed to sleep on the mats.
I was legit treated
pretty much like a dog.
When they let the kids outside to play
they hooked me up to a dog
runner, sometimes they'd
leave me out there all night.
I'm terribly afraid of the
dark, terrified of the dark.
I have an issue with bathrooms,
really just horrid fear.
I can never close the bathroom door.
I've always just got the shit
kicked out of me in bathrooms
and I don't wanna die
in a bathroom like that.
It scares me, that freaks me out.
Ever since I was a small
kid I just identified that
and I just, I still to
this day, I mean, I'll go
nine days without eating a single thing.
- Well, I mean-
- But I'm constantly
drinking things, but I just,
I literally don't get hungry.
I don't know what the sensation
of being hungry is like,
because I just voided it out,
because when you're
starving it hurts too much.
You just void it out, mind over matter.
I do truly believe that I can manifest.
I'm capable of anything I put my mind to,
but I just can't seem
to get the fuck out of
my own way lately (laughing), you know?
I lost my daughters and
my husband last summer
in a house fire.
All of them.
Now, mind you, I was 100% square.
I never even smoked a cigarette.
I've never been drunk, I've
never gone out clubbing,
to the bars, I've never
done anything in my life.
Anything, nothing, I
don't even have friends.
All I did was my family and
work, my family and work.
My husband got really, he stayed home.
He never had a job in his life,
since we were kids, everything.
He was a piece of shit, but
he was my piece of shit.
Mind you, I'm an orphan.
He didn't leave.
No matter what we ever went
through, he didn't leave me.
And I have abandonment issues.
So it was really important to me.
It was kids' father, supposed
to me and meant to be
and blah, blah, blah (blowing
raspberries), whatever.
19 years, we were perfectly happy.
We barely even had a
conflict of any sorts.
He never, ever yelled at children,
never put hands on the children.
I mean, he literally was an
amazing and fantastic father.
He was my best friend and my soulmate.
He was Jamaican.
His name is Demetrius (chuckling).
Now, mind you, as my business grew,
I got more and more
busy, more and more busy.
And I am super Jewish, very cheap.
I don't want to pay employees,
but I can do it all (chuckling).
It's just a bigger check.
So, I mean, I was working,
easily, 18 hour days.
Now this was summertime, maybe
two years ago, summertime.
He just started getting really
depressed, really different.
And I could tell
something was up with him,
but I was just too consumed,
too consumed in money and my career
and this, that, and the other.
I was kind of a superficial
bitch, to be honest with you.
And I just, I didn't have time for it.
And I just went about my business.
Well, come to find out,
well, when I found out
he was using drugs, I found
out about crystal meth.
He was slamming it and he
actually was slamming it
in his neck.
And then it turned into, very quickly,
drinking whole bottles,
he was actually slamming liquor at points.
He was out slamming everything
and anything in his neck.
When I caught him with drugs
and a significant amount of money,
I had around 140,000 in the bank
and I was down to, like, nine grand.
And what I realized this, first time ever,
he beat the ever living
dog shit out of me.
Tied me up and he shot me up
with heroin for the first time.
There's actually a scar on my neck
that's over two years old
and it won't ever go away.
He did it there, because
he was, at this time,
domestic violence started, started bad.
It went from 0 to 100 really quick.
Now, Demetrius, the reason
we never really partied,
got into drug stuff, he was schizophrenic,
which he told me about.
And I always knew, but I
never saw anything alarming
or any signs of that.
And people with mental
disorders, especially like that.
Now, he's a hardcore
schizophrenia, like scary shit.
Like a whole other person inside of him.
He took medication.
He always took medication
as long as I knew him
and it was never an issue.
And he stopped taking
medication, started using drugs
and it just, it got really bad.
I got really, really, really bad.
Not last summer, the summer before,
so that would be what, 2017?
He was strangling me daily, unconscious.
Putting me out, completely unconscious.
Now the thing with that is,
being strangled is something
that's very, very personal, you know?
And it comes a point and you'll
be looking up at this person
a man that I love more than anything,
the father of my children,
and you accept it.
You stop struggling.
You literally just, you stop.
You literally accept
whatever's gonna happen
is gonna happen.
That does something to you mentally.
And especially, I mean, sometimes it was
a couple of times a day,
several times a day.
He was literally, daily,
putting me out, strangling me.
And that's when I really
started having a hard time
and kind of accepting that obviously,
he's gonna kill me like
this, this was it, you know?
He'd just lost his fucking
mind, it was crazy.
He was, daily, getting
more and more demonic.
The way he moved, his
mannerisms, stuff he says
going into his episodes.
Before it'd be sometimes a couple seconds
and sometimes a couple minutes.
Now it was starting to last days.
The longest ever was six
days he left me tied up
in the bathroom and he was
putting cigarettes out on me.
I have over 100 of them all over my body,
which turned into staph
infection, which turned in MRSA,
which actually almost ended up killing me.
I had holes.
Some of them took over
a year to even heal.
I mean, I have them all over.
My genitals, my boobs, everything.
He just had some sick obsession
with just seeing me in pain.
And it was just evil.
And the kids, I kept
pushing the kids away,
and they really didn't see
much of it, believe it or
not, they really didn't.
Now, mind you, they're teenagers.
My kids, this year, would
have been 20, 18, 15, and 13.
So, and they just died last summer, so.
- [Mark] All of them?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] In the same fire?
- Yeah, their father
set their beds on fire
while they were asleep, and
he stabbed me five times,
then he killed himself.
- [Mark] You stabbed-
- Me, five times.
- [Mark] He stabbed you five times?
- I was on life support for months.
I actually just woke up February 15th
and then I came to Vegas.
- [Mark] Just six months ago, you?
- Yeah, just seeing me
you'd never think that, huh?
But yeah, I didn't even
get to bury my children
because there was nothing left of them.
And it's like my whole
life, now, mind you,
27 years old I bought that house.
I put $300,000 down on that house.
It was a half a million dollar
house, house of my dreams.
It was just so beautiful.
It was beautiful.
I manifested every little inch of it.
And the kids and everything.
I had a dog, Brody.
The only dog I'd ever
had in my entire life.
He was 17 years old, he was pitbull.
Pits only live 10 to 13
years, and he was 17.
He was amazing, the best.
He was the only boy, he's my boy.
He was amazing, the best dog in the world.
I got him when I was 19.
Now, mind you, nope,
nope, that was the cat.
I got the cat at 19.
I got him at 23 or something like that.
And just, he was amazing.
He died in the fire at the
foot of my middle daughter,
Tatiana, Tatiana was his kid.
He died at the foot of her
bed, like, right there.
He watched him do it, just
died, he laid there with her.
The worst part though is when
the screams stop, you know?
Because when someone-
- Where was-
My daughters' screaming stopped.
- Oh.
- Because I just, I knew
that that was it.
I listened to my kids burn to death.
- [Mark] So where were you when the kids
were in their room?
- I was tied up.
- Oh, you were tied up.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And how'd you escape the fire?
- I don't know.
The EMTs, they saved me, I don't
know why, I don't know how.
I have no idea why or how.
- [Mark] Wow, so the
paramedics got you out.
- Yeah, I don't know, I woke up.
- But they didn't
- I woke up in a hospital
and I thought it had just
been minutes, I had no idea.
And it was six months
and three days later.
They actually pulled
the plug at six months.
I had no brainwaves, nothing.
I was considered clinically dead.
And they pulled the plug at six months.
I actually remember, because
I could hear the priest
or whoever they have come
in and say something.
And I remember them
unplugging it and everything.
I could hear and kind of see
everything that was going on,
but I couldn't respond.
Now, that was the scariest
feeling in the world.
Feeling trapped inside your own body.
And there was different points in time,
I kind of vaguely remember seeing
and being able to hear things,
but I couldn't do anything.
I couldn't move, I couldn't
talk, I couldn't anything.
And I had no idea where I was, who I was,
what was going on, I
just was completely lost.
They pulled the plug at six months
and I just kept breathing.
And they were actually
kind of cracking jokes,
kind of peculiar.
And they left out the room
and I actually just woke up
three days later.
I just shot up, jumped up.
I just kind of panicked.
I went to stand up and
I fell flat on my face.
I was 77 pounds.
Yeah, 77 pounds.
And yeah, I'm like-
- [Mark] This was just February?
- Yeah, February 15th.
- [Mark] Wow.
- Actually day after
Valentine's Day, yeah.
Had to learn how to walk, talk,
eat, sleep, shit, breathe,
everything all over again.
It was awful, really awful.
- [Mark] So you're still
reeling from this, obviously.
- Yeah, yeah, I'm a mess.
I'm a hot mess.
- And you're on the street,
on Skid Row.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] And you're addicted to what?
- I'm a heroin addict.
- [Mark] Heroin.
Had you ever tried heroin
before this happened?
- I've never did any,
I've never smoked a cigarette in my life
until my husband shot me up my first time.
And even waking up from life support,
I didn't need it, I wasn't
physically addicted anymore,
but the first thing I wanted to do was,
I needed it, I needed it, I needed it.
Now, mind you, I'd never, ever
shot up before in my life.
So, my husband always hit me in the neck.
And I didn't know what to do.
I was a fucking hot mess.
Actually, a couple street
people ended up teaching me,
show me how to do it.
It was disgusting.
- Well, when you first
tried it, your goal was just to numb the-
- It was to kill myself, absolutely.
- Oh, to kill yourself?
- Absolutely.
I was furious they even saved me.
Why?
What the fuck?
Just, it made no sense.
Now, mind you, now I'm in
this rehabilitation center
and in the hospital.
Now all the sudden the police show up
and they wanna ask me some questions.
They basically tried to turn it all around
and said that I killed my family.
And even though forensics
proved that it was impossible
for me to stab myself in those angles.
Like, the worst one was right here.
Downwards with a steak knife.
It collapsed my lung
and just the tip of it
was right on my heart.
And they just thought,
it was just sketchy,
the way it all went down
and they wanted to ask me
some questions.
I just, I freaked, I
freaked, right, just out.
I mean, not only am I dealing
with all these things,
I couldn't even,
I hadn't even left the hospital rehab.
They told me, "This is
what happened," da-da-da.
I don't believe you, what
are you talking about?
This is all a bad dream,
I just wanna go home.
I remember the first thing
I did when I left that rehab
is I took the bus and I went to go home
and there's nothing
left, everything's gone.
Grass growing, it's fucking gone.
My entire life is just
- And you have
no family to go to, right?
- There's nothing.
Nothing was salvaged,
nothing, nothing whatsoever.
It's like my entire life just gone.
- [Mark] Yeah, not a soul
was able to do anything.
- Not a soul visited me in
the hospital, nobody calls me,
no nothing.
- Did you have a friend?
Anything?
- And as the domestic
violence got worse and worse,
over the last year and
a half of my marriage,
I just alienated even more and more.
And he's starting to
hold me hostage and shit,
nobody came to check on me, nobody.
The police came to my
residence over 60 times
for domestic violence
in that year and a half.
Literally over 60 times.
- [Mark] Wow.
- There's no reason that
my children should be dead.
They should have helped me,
they should have done something.
And everyone's like,
"Well, you let him back in.
"You love the abuse."
That's bullshit, because
you can only do so much.
I wrote reports, I put
five restraining orders on.
They literally dropped
them behind my back,
because as an American, you have rights,
your everyday rights.
Well, this is his residence,
this is his address.
He's lived here, he
has a right to be here,
he needs means to live.
So, regardless of what me
and him are going through,
by law, he's allowed to
be there, because that is
his residence.
I had to go through the
legal eviction process
and divorce him, to
get him out of my home.
Well, how the fuck am
I supposed to do that
when he's beating the
shit out of me daily?
He literally broke almost
every bone in my body.
Literally.
Horrific.
That's why I got a tattoo on my face,
because I got a plate
holding my face together.
It's crazy, it's absolutely insane.
I tried everything to help my husband.
I truly believed that I could save him.
I really did, and I couldn't (crying).
It was like, "You must like the abuse."
I hate those kind of comments,
because it's 19 years.
I mean, he was the love of my life.
He's literally all I knew, he was it.
He's my best friend and he
just, drugs just took him.
He wasn't even a person any more.
He started growing dreads the day,
we got married when I was 19.
He started growing his dreads then.
He had dreads past his ass.
He was ripping them out of his head.
There was fucking, like,
- Wait, so
- Blood splatters on the
frigging ceilings and shit.
He was, like, ripping his skin off.
He fucking cut one of his fingers off.
He was fucking crazy.
- [Mark] What do you think
was going on in his head?
- He was slamming bath salts at that time
and he was just completely demonic.
- [Mark] He was slamming what?
- Bath salt.
- [Mark] What's that?
- It's like a hallucinogenic.
It's kind of like crystal, but way worse.
- [Mark] Really?
- And it's just, he
was so, he was demonic.
Literally.
I literally believe that he was possessed.
Something took him over.
He wasn't the same person anymore.
And you could tell even just
by looking at him and stuff.
And he was completely
gone, completely gone.
And it was awful, it was really awful.
- [Mark] What made you come to California?
- After all that happened and
being released from the rehab,
police were more and more on
my tail about stupid things.
And they wanna talk, check in
with this, check in with that.
Now, mind you, I've never
been arrested in my life.
After being held hostage in
situations and stuff like that,
that's actually one of my biggest fears,
is being incarcerated or
being taken out of my will
and stuff like that.
I don't do good with authority.
I don't do good with feeling,
I hate being vulnerable in
any way, any way whatsoever.
I mean, the stupidest things.
When I'd fall asleep, he'd jump on me
and burn me with cigarettes,
you know what I mean?
Say you're naked in the shower,
what if someone breaks in?
You're wet, you're slippery,
what are you gonna do?
If there's no window in the bathroom
I won't even go in the bathroom.
Silly, little things.
They seem silly, but it's
literally survival to me.
I literally live every second, every day,
like I'm just waiting for
it, and it's fucked up.
Coming to California was,
well, mid-life crisis, right?
I lost everything.
I didn't have a pot to piss in
or a window to throw it out of.
Completely broke, bankrupt,
I lost everything.
My business, everything.
What does everybody do
in their midlife crisis?
They go to Vegas (laughing).
I was supposed to get a
sugar daddy and a new car.
I didn't work out.
Vegas was fun, Vegas was real.
I've never seen anything quite like Vegas.
I really had a blast in Vegas.
I was actually doing
pretty well for myself.
- [Mark] What were you doing?
- I was staying at hotels every night.
I was just hustling.
Honestly, I was
middle-manning selling drugs.
I was gambling.
I never prostituted.
I've actually never slept with
anyone other than my husband.
- Really?
- Until just this last year.
And one of them doesn't really count
because he jizzed in his pants (laughing).
Swear to god.
And the other one was just a recent thing.
And I mean (laughing), that was fun.
But other than that,
yeah, so to that point
I've never prostituted,
I've never done, really,
I mean, dabbled in drug
stuff here and there,
even when I was square.
But that was just kind of like,
get some money up real quick,
just take a ride with a ride,
drop this off, drop that off.
And I really didn't have
much to do with the drugs.
But I had a clean record, I'm
a pretty little Jewish girl.
I could get away with a lot of things
that these drug dealers
and these people couldn't.
I have a perfectly clean record.
I've had a driver's
license since I was 16.
I was just very put together,
I was very responsible,
I was very together.
And that was one thing.
Oh, when I was a kid (chuckling),
when I was an orphan.
The news people go around, they're like,
"Oh, hey shitty orphan,
"what do you wanna be when you grow up?"
And he's like, "I like turtles,"
stuff like that (laughing).
They actually came around,
I remember the day.
The news crew was like,
"Oh, what do you wanna be
"when you grow up?"
And I had the leg braces,
I was all screwed up,
the was like the worst
day ever and I remember
it was raining that day and I
was having a really bad day.
And I remember I'm like,
"I'm not really sure
"what I'm gonna be, but I
know every day I'm gonna
"get up, dress up, and show up.
"I'm gonna be anybody I wanna be."
And it's funny, because
when my house burnt down,
the last count I did was I
had a little over 600 dresses.
I had a new dress and heels every day.
And I would, I would get up every day.
And I'm a pretty girl, I know I'm pretty.
But I can take a $5 thrift
store dress and I can make it,
I can stop a whole room of people.
I just had a certain flair with that.
It was something about it.
I mean, when a woman
feels beautiful it shows.
And I really, just a
dress and heels every day.
And I've never spent more
than $20 on anything.
Anything, other than maybe a
car and my house (laughing).
I'm super cheap in my ways
and very, very thrifty.
But I'd go to thrift stores, spend $100,
and I'd turn that $100 quick into $500.
But I need a couple hours (laughing).
Like, shopping is just a
really serious thing with me.
I had four daughters,
had the dress shop, just,
it was my thing.
A majority of those dresses, actually,
when the house burnt down,
they were around $40,000
was what my clothes were worth.
Just alone, it was just amazing.
I had a closet probably
about the size of this room.
- [Mark] Whoa.
- It was amazing, truly amazing.
And it was really cool,
because my daughters
were now the size, they were beautiful.
They were Jamaican-Jews (laughing).
They were fricking beautiful.
Tall, skinny, but we're
all petite and everything.
So they were getting to the
age where they were really
starting to get into it and stuff, too.
So it was a lot of fun, it was cool.
We played dress-up every day.
Yeah, I just, it's crazy.
I really miss my kids.
And it's sad, I see,
especially on Skid Row,
none of these women have their children,
probably don't even
talk to their children.
And there is nothing in this
world that I wouldn't give,
just to have five more
minutes with my kids.
I worked so hard to make a
living, I forgot to live.
And even knowing, I remember
specific points when I knew,
"I need to talk to my
husband, something's wrong.
"He needs a hug," you know?
- What was your husband
doing for a living?
- Huh?
- What was your husband doing
for a living?
- He stayed at home.
Whatever he wanted (chuckling).
He was kind of,
- [Mark] So you were the
breadwinner, basically?
- Yeah, oh, yeah.
I always was the pants of
the relationship, I guess.
But he did a lot of tattooing.
That's pretty much all
my tattoos are from him.
He didn't really do anything,
but he was an incredible artist.
Definitely an incredible artist.
And he was just my best friend.
I didn't care.
I supported him, I took care of him.
And I've never been on a date.
I'm almost 38.
I've never gone out to eat
and not paid at least the tip.
I've never had a birthday cake.
I've never danced with anyone.
Never been to a wedding,
actually been to a wedding.
I've worked weddings.
I've never been to an amusement park.
I've never been to a cookout.
- You went to
your own wedding.
I've never been to a family function.
- [Mark] You had your own wedding.
- Not really, no.
We just signed shit at the-
- [Mark] Oh, is that right?
- Yeah, it was nothing.
My husband never gave me
anything, nothing, nothing, ever.
Not even anything.
And I called that love.
And it isn't about
materialistic things, it's not.
But he drained 140,000 in nine months
and left just everything.
So when my house burnt down,
I had everything set up
on automatic bill pay.
I didn't open my mail and shit.
When my house burnt down I
didn't even have house insurance.
And nothing had been paid
in around about nine months.
And they were coming after me
for the cleanup of my house.
And just put the cherry on top.
And I'm looking at, I have
a bunch of outstanding,
very serious warrants right
now, that if the police get me,
I could probably do life.
And I've never been to
jail a day in my life.
After all this happened,
before I left New York,
I mean, I lost my mind a little bit.
I had a really hard time.
I mean, everything and everybody
I'd ever known was gone,
(snapping fingers)
like that.
And I'm an orphan, I've
got abandonment issues.
It's serious.
And now, they say it's
better to have loved and lost
and all this other shit, and
I'd rather have never, ever,
ever known him at all.
I don't think I'll ever
even really have sex again.
I'm good, I'm done with it.
These fucking men, they're disgusting.
These, honestly, no exaggeration,
at least five men a day
hit on me, somehow, someway.
- Well,
- At least.
- You have to understand you're in the
asshole of-
- Absolutely, but even
before I was here, I
mean, anywhere I ever was.
I even walk down a street, she knows.
I'm sure you know, too.
Walk down the street, I could
just go to the corner store
and I'm solicited,
somehow, someway, for sex.
- Well, I'm mean,
- Every single time.
- There are all kinds of men,
- Absolutely.
- Just like there are all types of women.
And there are good guys out there.
- Oh, absolutely, no absolutely.
But every single time, it's annoying.
But not a single one of these
men ask me out to dinner,
even hold a conversation
with me, without mentioning
their dick within the first three minutes.
That's alarming.
- You're hanging out
with the wrong crowd.
- You're talking grown men.
That's alarming.
And I mean, I'm pretty,
I dress, I don't know.
I guess they'd say it's
sexy, I'm not really sure.
But I've never been slutty,
you know what I mean?
My boobs, my ass ain't hanging out.
I'm not running around here hooking.
So, I don't understand,
one thing is like, society,
even this other girl I was
talking to the other day.
She's like, "Oh yeah, I met him,"
she met this guy at a bar or whatever,
she went in the bathroom
and she sucked his dick.
She's like, "Oh, I just sucked his dick."
And I remember it's like a bus hit me.
I was like, "You just?"
She took it so lightly,
like, "Oh, just no big deal.
"I just," what (laughing)?
One in, like, three people have an STD.
That's not even the
infection, that's diseases.
And especially on Skid
Row, I hear there's HIV's
popping up wicked hard, because
everyone's sharing needles
and everything's going crazy.
And that's a very alarming number.
That is very scary.
And not everybody just,
if anybody can have it,
it's no longer valuable, you know?
And you can't just let
anybody run up in you
and through you and around.
You are the company you keep they say.
And there's a lot of
truth to that statement.
And I keep thinking I'm gonna get a tent
and I'm gonna do this
and I'm gonna do that.
And I feel like if I get a
tent, then I'm accepting it.
Every day I spend here, I
feel like I'm less likely
to ever leave.
And this is really like the
end of the line, this place.
It really, truly is.
I'm not trying to be dramatic.
- No, there's nothing worse
- This is the end of the
fucking line.
I have seen some of the most
disgusting, most horrendous
- There's no place worse
than this.
Maybe in Africa.
- Saddest things
I've ever seen, they're here.
And most heinous things.
I mean, I was actually even
beat up by a bunch of guys,
almost gang raped and
frigging drug into a tent
and everything, like, about a month ago.
And they kept me there a good, at least,
probably 15, 20 hours.
But it was terrifying.
It was absolutely terrifying.
It was very demeaning.
It was awful.
And actually, I left Skid Row.
This is actually the first
time I've come up since.
I've been up by airport, LAX.
It's like highway of planes.
I've never seen that before, that's crazy.
I've also never been on a
plane, boat, nothing like that.
So it was really, really funky.
First time I ever seen
a palm tree was May 12th
when I went to Vegas.
That was pretty cool.
- So where are you
staying now?
- Right now I'm not staying anywhere.
I just wander, I just keep wandering.
I don't really sleep, I don't really stop.
I just wander.
- [Mark] And how do you
pay for your heroin.
- I boost mostly, to be honest.
I'm very, very thrifty in my ways.
Sometimes not even necessarily boosting,
not even necessarily stealing.
I find things, I seem
to come across things.
Like I said, powerful mind.
I really think I focus on
something and it happens.
I kind of figure it out.
Literally, I found a box
of big packs of batteries.
AA and AAA, I just went
around and sold them
and this, that, and the other.
Brand new shoes, clothing,
I mean, you name it,
I can turn around, I can
sell ice to an Eskimo.
And that's one thing I'm marketing, too.
And I was just, I'm really
good at being thrifty.
Making a dollar into $10, $10 into 20,
just building myself up.
It takes me longer to get
there, but I can look myself
in the mirror at the end of
the day and know who I am.
That's okay.
- [Mark] And do you have any plans for the
next five years or so?
- I don't believe in plans.
Plans are made to be broken.
And any moment, nothing's
guaranteed, nothing's,
everything, eventually,
is gonna be the last time.
I don't even really want friends.
I don't even wanna get close
to anything or feel too much.
At this point, honestly,
drugs are the only thing
that makes me feel anything.
And I'm scared to come down.
I can't, I can't mentally
deal with the things
that have happened.
I've never been to a therapist.
I've never seen,
they gave me no victim's assistance.
They don't give a flying fuck about me,
and I'm America's kid.
I'm literally an orphan.
Where's my crazy check?
Where's my help?
I've never even got a food
stamp, I've never got shit.
And I feel some kind of way about that.
Not that I feel like
anyone owes me anything.
They don't.
But I can't work a regular
9:00 to 5:00 at this point.
I can't even stand and being
me sometimes (chuckling).
It's a hot mess.
And with the heroin,
but I'm actually doing
really good with that.
I'm down to only, like, 10, $20 a day.
And that's keeping me okay.
I'm not great, but I'm
okay, I'm functioning.
And I know, honestly, in my
heart that this is a phase.
I'd probably wake up random one morning,
because I was never an addict before,
and I will probably just
stop, (snapping) like that.
I guarantee you.
Honestly, I probably will.
I don't know for sure, because
I can't tell the future,
but this isn't fun.
My arms hurt, they hurt terribly.
I'm a fucking mess.
It feels like shit.
My frigging bumps, everything.
It hurts horribly and shooting up.
But I can compare shooting
up to self-mutilation,
you know the teenagers
and cutting themselves?
Very much like that, because
the whole ritual of it.
Even though my whole
world's so out of control,
it's one thing I have control of.
And it helps, it eases the
pain, numb and suppress.
And when I do get dope
sick, when I don't have it,
whatever, I do, it's scary.
I'm a danger to myself
and others, absolutely.
Extremely suicidal, extremely depressed
extremely angry, hurt.
I can't handle the loss of my children.
I really can't, I still haven't,
because I never had closure.
There's no funeral.
There's no goodbye.
They're just gone and I miss them.
- [Mark] Sara, thank you
so much for talking to me.
- Thank you, I appreciate it.
- [Mark] Just an incredible story.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Thank you.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] I've seen
people who have come from
terrible, terrible situations
that are beautiful.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And then on the
opposite to these people,
they've accomplished
things, they've become
great role models for their children.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] And they've become
cool people that you wanna know.
- Mm-hmm.
- Not the kind of people
that you wanna avoid.
- Absolutely.
- [Mark] And that's where
I think you may fall,
somewhere in, that's
why people are reacting
the way there are.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] They're just
like, "No, this couldn't be
"for real, look at her.
"She's to beautiful
and she's put together,
"and she's well-dressed, she's articulate.
"She's accomplished."
Four master's degrees.
- Fake it until you make it.
Yeah, yeah.
- You got four
master's degrees from what school?
- I went to Boston.
Boston, Boston, Boston, but my biggest,
I did classes in Boston,
which really intrigued me
to push a little further,
because I struggled.
Now, I was-
- [Mark] Boston College?
- Valedictorian in New York and
fucking all this other shit.
Now, I went to Boston and I felt stupid.
- [Mark] Boston College?
- Yeah, just the straight,
community, fucking,
not community, I can't
fucking think, community,
not the community college, but
the, not Harvard (laughing).
But it was the, where
the neighborhood kids go.
It was like classes,
but so now, I graduated
from York County Technical College.
- [Mark] Okay.
- Which is where they sent me.
Now, I struggled very,
very hard in Boston.
And it wasn't even like
a Harvard kind of school, whatsoever.
But I really, first semester
I was ready to drop out.
- [Mark] So it wasn't
Boston College, it was York?
- Well no, I graduated from
York County Technical College
in Wells, Maine.
- [Mark] Got it.
- In Wells, Maine.
This was all part of my rebuilding myself.
- Yeah.
- I got out of New York
- What year did
you graduate?
- And I went North.
Huh?
- [Mark] What year did you graduate?
- I graduated high school 2002.
I graduated college, I had
a little ceremony each year,
because I accomplished such
great things through each year,
but I got finished, finished
college in, it's was '08?
Yeah, '08.
- [Mark] You can't discount that
in the slightest.
- I'm not the same person
that I was.
My memory, my everything,
I'm falling the fuck apart.
- Yeah.
- Like, I'm losing it.
- [Mark] Well, I mean, look at you.
You just got beat up.
I just talked to you a couple days ago
and now you've gotten
beaten up since then.
- Yeah, and I didn't just get beat up,
I got the shit kicked out of me.
- [Mark] By who?
- The big fucking fat chick.
She just didn't like me.
I literally never seen
her before in my life.
Big girl.
She had a mohawk kind of haircut,
tattoos all over her face,
and her hair was like, lime green.
And she walked by me on the dead end road,
where I was telling
you that I was staying.
And she just said something
like, "Stupid bitch."
Something like that, and
I was just like, "What?"
And she just, I turned
around and kept walking,
she came up from behind
me and jump whomped me
upside down the back of my head.
And I fell flat and she just beat the
every living shit out of me.
And all these people that
I've been living amongst,
known, supposedly my friends, right?
Nobody did a fucking thing.
She legit beat the shit out
of me at least 15 minutes,
at least.
- [Mark] Mm.
- Literally, and just
kept going and going.
Knocked one of my teeth out.
- [Mark] And you can't
call the police because of
what you've-
- Nope, there's no
calling cops, there's no calling cops.
- [Mark] Because of what you explained
last time?
- Anything, just anything,
you know what I mean?
- Knocked a tooth out?
- Snitches get stitches.
Huh?
- [Mark] You lost a tooth?
- Yeah, right here, broke my tooth.
- [Mark] Oh, nice.
- Yeah, great, right?
I've never been to a dentist in my life
and I had perfect, beautiful teeth,
and they're just going to shit
- You've never been
to a dentist?
- I've never been to
a dentist in my life.
- For a checkup?
I'm petrified.
- [Mark] So what city was
your family, the house in?
- [Sara] Somersworth, New Hampshire.
- [Mark] Somersworth, New Hampshire.
- [Sara] Yeah, but they didn't
get into details of exactly,
because of protection
of, it was a big deal.
But there was, "Foster's Daily Democrat".
It's all boiled down.
But they didn't get into
the address and everything.
They actually protected me a lot in the-
- [Mark] Yeah, because it
was basically a murder.
- Yeah, yeah,
- It wasn't just,
absolutely it was.
I mean, he killed the kids,
he attempted to kill me,
and he killed himself.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Sara] And a lot of it
was on now his family.
Another thing, there's laws protecting
where he's deceased, his
family needed to be notified
before, there's certain laws, they can't,
like, say someone commits suicide or,
someone commits suicide.
- [Mark] Right.
- [Sara] They don't go and make it public
until the family's properly
notified and then they come out
with whatever article or
whatever, how they're gonna
put it out to the public,
if they put it out
to the public.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Sara] There's a lot of
things that were protection
because of his family.
I knew that.
And his family often, also,
was trying to come after me.
Trying to say that
basically I did everything.
They thought it was
coincidence, how come I'm alive
and they're all dead and everything else.
Now, mind you, in all the years
that me and him were together,
his family never, never,
I never met his family.
They didn't want nothing to do with me.
They were just furious that
he was with a white woman.
- [Mark] Oh, really?
- Oh yeah, absolutely.
They wanted nothing to do with nothing
until the day that he died.
People don't, they're not nice to me.
People are not nice to me.
I'm automatically judged.
I mean, especially out in California.
I've never experienced racism
as much as I have out here.
I have been treated like shit out here.
- [Mark] Well, and you're hanging out
in dangerous neighborhoods.
- Yeah, I've been from
one slum to the other, yeah.
- And I've been here,
I've been here for a few decades
and
- But I mean, how the fuck
do I break that?
How do I get out of this?
I mean, honestly, Mark, I
would give fucking anything
just to have one fucking normal day.
Just normal day, I don't
wanna do this (crying).
This shit's like, literally killing me.
Like, I'm breaking, I'm
fucking going crazy.
I literally feel like I'm losing my shit.
Like, I've never been beat up.
Like, what the fuck?
Just random, just people standing around
like it's a fucking show.
Nobody gives a fuck.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- No one gives a fucking fuck.
I'm literally pissing blood.
Nobody gives a fuck.
I don't get it, I'm not like that.
In my whole entire life, I've
never even thrown a punch.
I've never been in a fight.
This girl is just beating
the fucking snots out of me
and people are laughing, making jokes.
It was all at my expense, every time.
It's exhausting, it's
really fucking exhausting.
And I don't know what to do.
And even though, like, I
don't wanna go back there.
But where else am I gonna go?
Literally?
Just sit on a sidewalk somewhere?
- Yeah, well that's what these people do.
And that's what you're doing, basically.
- That's the point that I'm getting at.
- Yeah.
- It's just one day to the next.
And I can't even bring myself
to sleep with these people.
And then I get, I was
raped, really, overall.
I mean, I can't even
butter it up any other way.
I was straight out raped.
I mean, yeah, I didn't kick and scream,
"Oh no, don't, stop."
Because if I did that,
I'd just get the shit
kicked out of me and knocked out.
But there's nothing I
can fucking do about it.
They've literally taken all my belongings,
shuffled through, and kept what they want
and just thrown the rest on the floor,
on the ground.
- Sure.
- They don't give a fuck.
- [Mark] Yeah, here on the street,
the fact that you're
white and your attractive,
they see such a target.
- They wanna pit me.
- Beat you up,
- All they wanna do is
sell me.
- [Mark] You're exactly who they hate.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So you're gonna get,
- Absolutely.
- [Mark] Right.
- And I get it, every fucking angle.
- You're a target for
- Every goddamn angle.
So many of these people.
- Women, men, Black, white.
- They're anger.
- It doesn't even matter.
Every single angle I get it.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Yeah, you need to get off the street.
- I really do, because I'm telling you,
I don't even think I could
do three more months of this.
I really can't.
If you were to see me,
even a year ago until now,
it's alarming, it's scary.
- [Mark] No, you'll be dead in six months.
- Literally.
- [Mark] Either from drugs or from worse.
- If I'm lucky, drugs.
But mostly likely fucking
- If you're lucky (chuckling).
- Probably beaten or fucking
raped to death or murdered,
honestly.
And it's to that point.
I mean, even after the girl
beat me up the other day
and then he slept there that night,
he got up, I was doing something.
I was cleaning up, the dogs were barking,
because he's got a couple
dogs and everything too.
And I was cleaning up dog
shit and I dropped a piece.
And it was dark out.
Dropped a piece, and he
got up for some reason,
he steps in it.
He fucking smacked me so hard, I swear,
he launched me to the back of that wall.
Just with one cuff, right
upside down my head.
After I'd already gotten beat up that day.
And I started bleeding.
I was bleeding out my ear,
like, from him slapping me
so hard.
It's like when you have a bloody nose,
but it was coming out my ear.
What the, like?
And once again, nobody
said a fucking thing.
There's people all
around, constantly, 24/7.
Nobody, they're just gonna
turn a cheek, you know?
- [Mark] For what
- But who died
and made this motherfucker God?
Why does he got so much pull and power?
Because he's nothing but a hood-booger.
He's nothing but a piece of shit.
- [Mark] So, throughout your
life, before the house fire
and your husband losing his mind,
- Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] Were you basically
an unlucky person,
or a lucky person, or
how do you see yourself?
- I've never been luck in any way.
Everything I've ever got
I've worked for, tenfold.
Every mistake I've ever made,
- No, but-
- I paid for tenfold.
I mean, any wrong doing
that I've ever done,
I had paid for.
- But you had a
successful business in New York.
- I did have a successful business, yeah.
But that was really
blood, sweat, and tears.
It was really,
- Yeah, well that's
how it works.
- I had to work hard for it.
- Yeah, that's what I mean.
- The only way I really had
success and breakthroughs
is because I really,
not to sound cocky, but
I really am brilliant.
I really am outside the box.
I can think of something.
Give me a pile of fabric and I'll make it
into something amazing.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- And really, what launched my business,
what made my business really successful,
which actually is very, very
fucked up to be honest with you
is, you know the saying, "Shoot
your local heroin dealer"?
I actually got an old, rickety
screen-printing machine
to do T-shirts and stuff.
And that was actually when
the heroin thing was kind of
really starting to show its face.
And my kids were middle school,
just starting high school,
and it was terrifying.
Heroin's everywhere and da-da-da.
And I was just, God forbid, you know?
This could be our kids,
this could be our kids.
And I actually did this
whole little pep rally
and rally with the kids' school.
And I screen-printed a bunch of T-shirts,
"Shoot Your Local Heroin Dealer"
and that's basically
what blew my business up.
It's what made everybody
notice me, you know?
Like, "Oh wow, she's
really on a good track.
"Four daughters and"-
- Your T-shirts said,
"Shoot Your Local Heroin Dealer"?
- Yeah, we screen-printed a bunch of them,
"Shoot Your Local Heroin
Dealer" (laughing).
Because this is also,
mind you, New Hampshire.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Kind of a hillbilly-ish kind of place.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I was new
to the area.
- And now here you are,
- So, you know, and I mean
it was just something outside the box.
- About heroin.
- And it launched my business,
it really did.
I really came a long way with that.
And now, very ironically,
years later, here I am,
a heroin addict.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Tell me that's not just
fucked, really fucked.
- [Mark] Oh yeah, it's amazing.
- The breech of my success
became probably, maybe,
my biggest downfall.
- [Mark] Yeah, the other thing
that's hard to swallow is,
any woman whose four kids
are murdered by her husband,
would break.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Would break.
And you don't seem to be broken.
So, maybe you're in denial
a little bit.
- But I am.
To be honest,
- Maybe you're toughened
from what you came through.
- I look good.
I'm just good, fake it until you make it,
you know what I mean?
No matter what I've ever gone through,
no matter how bad I got
beat up, you put makeup on
and you still show up.
- [Mark] You might be a perfect
example of how resilient
the human being can be.
- Possibly, but I don't really feel it.
- Not today (chuckling).
- I really don't feel it.
No, really just recently and increasingly,
especially, I'd say, the last few months.
I'm not playing, Mark, I'm losing it.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I'm really starting to
forget every day normal things.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I can't even remember
a full day of even being
with my children.
That's scary.
- No, eventually you'll
get used to this lifestyle
and you will end up,
- That's what I'm starting to,
- You'll become,
- And it's not good.
- The girls that are
sleeping on the street.
- I've debated even getting
a tent, right?
So I had my own space
so I could keep my shit.
But I feel like if I do
that, it's accepting it.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- And if I do that, I'm
gonna put all this energy
into keeping this tent and
da-da-da and to keep this
safe and clean and this,
that, that I'm going to
die in that fucking tent.
- [Mark] Right.
- Because I'm never
gonna have nothing more.
And that's why I just
keep pushing and pushing
to just roll with the punches.
Hopefully I'm gonna
catch a break somewhere.
But I'm a fucking Jew,
I'm not gonna catch no break (laughing).
(Mark laughing)
I'm the most unlucky woman you ever met
in your fucking life.
Everything that could possible go wrong,
in any situation, it does.
And everyone's like,
"Well, that's because
you put that out there,
"you put that energy out there."
And I'm a firm believer
in the laws of attraction
and all that, you know what I mean?
I manifested everything in my life.
We are nothing but what we have thought.
I get that.
But it's not that I'm being negative,
but it's being realistic.
Because I can't build myself up and,
"Oh, it's gonna be a great, super day."
But when it's not, it's
gonna really crush me.
So I just need to be like,
"Okay, if it does, great.
"But if it doesn't, okay."
I gotta prepare myself for the worst
because that's what I'm used to.
- [Mark] Sara, thank you for coming back.
- Thank you.
- And clarifying
some of this stuff for me.
- Appreciate it.